eine Atombombe im Weltall um dutzende
Satelliten zu zerstören das hat China in
dieser Simulation hier durchgerechnet
und anschließend sogar selber
veröffentlicht müssen wir also Angst vor
einer chinesischen Atombombe im Weltall
haben wie verwundbar ist unsere
kritische Infrastruktur da oben und was
hat das Paper mit dem Leck an Nord
Stream 2 und den Sabotagen bei der
Deutschen Bahn zu tun wir haben uns
angeguckt was über unseren Köpfen abgeht
und ordnen dass chinesische paper für
euch ein
nordstream 2 das Unterseekabel in
Frankreich die Deutsche Bahn die
Attacken auf unsere kritische
Infrastruktur häufen sich in letzter
Zeit gut bei Kabeln und Pipelines ist es
auch nicht so kompliziert eines zu
zerbeln Kabel zum Beispiel liegen nun
mal unbewacht irgendwo in unserer
Landschaft herum und im Endeffekt kann
sich jeder Depp einen Bagger schnappen
und los buddeln aber bei einem anderen
zentralen Baustein unserer kritischen
Infrastruktur sollte man meinen dass man
sie nicht ganz so leicht kaputt kriegt
ja das ist schon es geht um Satelliten
leider sind sie nicht einmal halb so
sicher wie man vielleicht denken mag und
das ist sagen wir nicht ganz
unproblematisch denn für unsere
Zivilisation ist Satellitentechnik sehr
wichtig ohne GPS beispielsweise würde
unsere Navigation ausfallen und ohne
Navigation unser globaler Warenverkehr
auch die Kommunikation Wetterberichte
Krisenhilfe wissenschaftliche Forschung
und die Taktung der Börsen würden ohne
die Arbeiter kaum mehr funktionieren und
der Ukraine kriegt demonstriert auch für
das Militär ist Satelliten-Internet
unentbehrlich denn die
Kommunikationsinfrastruktur am Boden
wird von Russland ganz gezielt
bombardiert und zerstört daher war ich
das ukrainische Militär zunehmend auf
internetsatelliten wie starlink aus
deren Funktionalität aber wiederum von
der Laune eines einzelnen Mannes abhängt
und dieser Mann wurde 2021 sogar vom
Time Magazine zur Person of the Year
ernannt und ja ich lese noch Magazine
diese alten verstaubten Dinge aus toten
Bäumen die bei euren Eltern im Regal
liegen denn da gibt's oft richtig
spannende Artikel die mich dann auf gute
Videoideen bringen die man aber irgendwo
anders zu lesen bekommt falls Ihr euch
dieses Jahr auch vorgenommen habt
endlich mal wieder mehr zu lesen euch
aber Magazine und Zeitungen vielleicht
einfach zu teuer geworden sind oder easy
nicht mehr immer mit euch rumschleppen
wollt dann habe ich was für euch nämlich
weedly hier habt ihr ein Abo dass ich im
ersten Monat gerade mal 99 Cent kostet
und euch Zugriff auf knapp 6000 Magazine
und Zeitungen gibt mein Favorit ist
natürlich Spektrum der Wissenschaft weil
wir mit denen auch gerne
zusammenarbeiten es gibt wirklich so
viele spannende Artikel die mit viel
Aufwand von Journalistinnen und
Journalisten aus der ganzen Welt
geschrieben werden die man einfach nicht
kostenlos im Internet findet denn guter
und unabhängiger Journalismus hat
einfach seinen Preis checkt gerne meinen
Link in der Beschreibung und im
angepinnten Kommentar damit bekommt ihr
einen Monat weekly für nur 99 Cent und
wir können jederzeit wieder kündigen und
jetzt lass uns erstmal genau mit diesem
unabhängigen Journalismus weitermachen
es gibt nämlich noch einiges zu
Satelliten was ich euch erzählen muss
aber auch ohne die Launen und
strategischen Spielchen eines
privatunternehmers ist unsere
Infrastruktur im All viel verwundbarer
als uns lieb ist prinzipiell werden
Satelliten sowieso schon von Trummer
Teilen im All Sonnenwinden Angriffen auf
die Steuerungseinheiten am Boden und
ganz wichtig Cyberangriffen bedroht
hinzu kommen jetzt aber noch die
verschiedenen großen Militärs dieser
Welt denn tatsächlich ist ein Staat der
mit Gewalt Satelliten vom Himmel holen
möchte an sich nichts Neues sowohl China
als auch die USA Indien und Russland
sind in der Lage mit
anti-satellitenraketen sogenannten acet
Raketen ganz gezielt Satelliten
abzuschießen das ist schon ein paar mal
gemacht worden und war jedes Mal ein
Riesending aber dazu kommen wir gleich
noch denn da oben geht viel mehr ab als
man im Alltag mitbekommt die
Technologien der verschiedenen Militärs
reichen von Roboterarmen bis hin zu
Satelliten die ganz zufällig an anderen
vorbei fliegen um herauszufinden was sie
so den lieben langen Tag machen und an
hoch energetischen Lasern wird auch
geforscht
russland hat neulich sogar einen
Satelliten gestartet der kleinere
Satelliten geschmuggelt hat woher sie
dieses Design wohl haben also das
Wettrüsten ist seit Jahrzehnten im Gange
und wenn eine der Weltmächte wirklich
wollte könnte sie vermutlich alles aus
der Erdumlaufbahn holen was ihr nicht
passt allerdings ist erstens unklar ob
der jeweils andere Staat das als
Kriegshandlung Werten und zum
Gegenschlag ausruhen würde und zweitens
ist allen Beteiligten ziemlich klar dass
sie sich damit auch zeitnah ins eigene
Knie schießen würden denn Satelliten
Abschlüsse haben einen unschönen
Nebeneffekt sie produzieren ganz schön
viel kleinteiligen Müll beim letzten
satellitenabschluss durch Russland sind
aus einem Flugobjekt
1500 Trümmerteile geworden die sich im
Orbit verteilt haben und wir haben jetzt
schon viel zu viele Dinge dort oben mit
jedem weiteren Flugobjekt in der
Erdumlaufbahn wird die Gefahr einer
Kollision und letzten Endes des
sogenannten kessler-syndroms größer also
dass wir irgendwann auf der Erde
eingeschlossen sein könnten
zu diesem Thema findet übrigens in
diesem Video hier und auch abgesehen vom
kessler-syndrom sind unkontrollierte
Trümmerteile für alles gefährlich was da
oben so kreist beim letzten
satellitenabschluss musste sogar die
Besatzung der ISS vorübergehen in
angedockten Raumschiffen in Sicherheit
gebracht werden warum starten die Länder
dann trotzdem diese gelegentlichen
satellitenabschüsse uns sind drei Gründe
begegnet von den forschende vermuten
dass sie dahinter stecken könnten der
erste ist dass tatsächlich die testen
solche Raketen die Staaten wollen sicher
gehen dass ihr Zeug funktioniert der
zweite ist eine Form der Abschreckung
ähnlich wie Militärmanöver auf der Erde
und der dritte mögliche Grund ist eine
Demonstration von Stärke seht her wir
sind eine Weltraum macht oder auf
Deutsch wir haben den längeren
trotzdem sind sich im Prinzip alle einig
dass mehr Weltraumschrott eine verdammt
schlechte Idee ist die USA haben daher
verkündet dass sie keine acetraketen
mehr testen wollen tatsächlich ist der
letzte amerikanische asset-einsatz
bereits über eine Dekade her oder man
macht es wie die Chinesen man simuliert
eine neue Strategie mit der man
Satelliten mit möglichst wenig
Weltraumschrott kaputt kriegt eine
Atombombe in Erdnähe zum Beispiel
also erst einmal warum hat China
simuliert wie man Starling zerstören
könnte aus Chinas Sicht gilt das
Netzwerk als Sicherheitsproblem die
Satelliten könnten Chinas Feinden ein
Kommunikationsnetz zur Verfügung stellen
sagen sie und ja das ist auch die Idee
des ganzen Dings außerdem könnten die
Satelliten als Suizid Satelliten
verwendet werden um gezielt in andere
freundliche Satelliten zu crashen so
sorgen sich die Chinesen also hätten sie
gerne die Möglichkeit Starling
auszuschalten wann immer Sie wollen das
herkömmliche asset Raketen nicht taugen
hatten wir ja gerade schon nicht nur
wegen des Kessler Syndroms sondern auch
wegen der Struktur von starlink das
Netzwerk von SpaceX ist so designt dass
einzelne Satelliten verzichtbar sind es
braucht also etwas mit mehr Wumms am
besten einen
Atombombe zum Beispiel konkret soll sie
in 80 km Höhe explodieren ihre nukleare
Wolke bereitet sich laut der
Simulationsdaten innerhalb von fünf
Minuten bis auf 500 km dann höher und
eine Fläche von Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg zusammen aus die
geringe Höhe bei der Sprengung hat den
Vorteil dass sich ihre radioaktive Wolke
richtig entfalten kann weil ihr hier
noch Sauerstoff für die Explosion zur
Verfügung steht außerdem gelangen die
radioaktiven Teilchen die so entstehen
laut der Simulation wohl nicht in die
Erdumlaufbahn sondern fallen zurück auf
die Erde praktisch da bin ich
erleichtert bevor das passiert soll die
Bombe jedoch möglichst viele starlings
Satelliten stören beschädigen oder sogar
aus der Gefecht setzen die Satelliten
werden also im Gegensatz zu normalen
Abschlüssen nicht zwangsläufig in
Trümmerteile zerlegt sondern einfach
untauglich gemacht jetzt kommt aber der
Witz bei der Sache
Massenvernichtungswaffen im All und dazu
gehören Nuklearwaffen logischerweise
sind so ungefähr das einzige bei dem
sich mal alle supermächtigeeinigt haben
und es verboten haben und das Sagen
Chinesen auch selber also was soll das
Ganze warum simulieren sie dann trotzdem
so einen Angriff
weil sie es können und weil sie wollen
dass alle wissen dass sie es könnten im
Endeffekt spielen alle weltraummächte
wer hat den größeren alle Versuche das
Wettrüsten mit einem internationalen
Vertrag zu stoppen sind gescheitert ob
jetzt China und Russland oder die USA
daran schuld sind ist schwer zu sagen
ihr könnt euch diese Quelle mal ansehen
da geben alle drei ihre Statements dazu
ab auf uns wirkte dass er wie das
reinste schwarze Peter Spiel
trotzdem sollte man natürlich nicht
unbesorgt sein wenn über unseren Köpfen
ein Wettrüsten stattfindet aber solche
Droge werden wie Chinas Simulation eines
atombombenangriffs aus Starling haben
auch immer eine Prise von
psychologischer Kriegsführung wir sollen
das Gefühl haben dass nichts mehr sicher
ist und wir uns am besten gar nicht
rühren damit uns nicht alles um die
Ohren fliegt auch dieser Montage Akte an
Nord Stream 2 Frankreichs Internetkabel
oder der Deutschen Bahn könnte man so
interpretieren
was können wir also tun nun erstens uns
von solchen Meldungen nicht verrückt
machen lassen keine Panik aber natürlich
auch trotzdem zweitens Strategien
entwickeln wie wir unsere kritische
Infrastruktur im Weltall auch physisch
schützen können die verschiedenen
Militärs sind hier am aufrüsten
Franzosen haben zum Beispiel erst vor
kurzem ein neues Programm gestartet es
sieht unter anderem vor Satelliten mit
Laserwaffen auszustatten damit sie sich
gegen einen Angriff wehren können
außerdem wollen sie nano-satelliten ins
All schicken die unfreundliche
Bewegungen oder Trümmer aufspüren sollen
an ähnlichen Abwehrsystemen bastelt auch
China und auch die Bundeswehr hat 2021
ein eigenes weltraumkommando gegründet
das Infrastruktur schnell aus dem
Gefahrenbereich schaffen oder
elektromagnetisch schützen können sollen
aber lasst uns besser hoffen dass die
wortwörtlichen Star Wars bei
Simulationen und sehr belassen bleiben
auch auf launische Privatunternehmer hat
die EU übrigens reagiert erst vor
wenigen Monaten hat sie den Aufbau eines
eigenen satelliteninternetz beschlossen
ihres hoch 2 denn aktuell ist auch die
EU genauso wie die Ukraine von
Drittanbietern abhängig was
Satelliten-Internet angeht mit dem neuen
Netz soll sich das ändern ab 2027 sollen
sowohl Bürger als auch Unternehmen
darüber kommunizieren können aber ihres
hoch 2 wird natürlich auch militärischen
Gefahren ausgesetzt sein deswegen
Lösungsideen Nummer drei abrüsten und
zwar alle oder zumindest klare Regeln
aufstellen die Staaten sind Tiere beim
Gespräch aber es gibt vieles worüber sie
sich einig werden müssen wollen sie eher
Technik oder eher Aktionen verwandeln
soll es freiwillig oder ein rechtlich
bindendes Verbot sein und haben die
Staaten mehr Sorge vor Attacken aus dem
All auf die Erde oder auf ihre
Infrastruktur im All die USA haben alle
Staaten aufgerufen ihre Ansichten zu
diesen Fragen einzureichen und einige
Antworten sind schon eingetrudelt
zu guter letzt noch eine geniale Idee
aus der Optimisten Ecke wie wäre es mit
einem einzigen Satelliten-Internet von
dem wir alle abhängen das löst das
kessler-problem das Start Privatproblem
und Chinas Atombomben Ambitionen die
Chinesen schießen sich dann nämlich
wenigstens auch selbst offline aber ja
sowas wird wahrscheinlich nie geben gut
also nicht gut aber gut in diesem Sinne
lasst euch nicht verrückt machen euer
Cedric